the library is and always has been a
great place for students to gather and
work together
technology is now becoming more
widespread and we rely on it
every day
this has been a long journey trying to
find the perfect design to fit the needs
of teachers and students
eventually someone came up with a
solution
it was perfect
hi so this guy came in my office and
wanted to design some tables for his
library
and i was like oh yeah man sure what do
you want him to be like
and he was like here's what the joint
looks like we need 30 computers
to fit in here and i was like find you
mate and then he left
there it goes what do you what do you
think of the positives and negatives of
this design
well um multiple access points
is just the multiple access points well
the polls are also
not like a big safety hazard now yes
so we're so how so over here
yeah okay
oh yeah okay you do you say any bad
things about that
okay how was the library redesigned well
in a physical
method the tables were rearranged and
more computers were added
this was to improve student experience
what we aim to do is to revolutionize
the way people use the library
how it works how it runs and how it's
used every day with the current system
we'll change it to make everything more
efficient for teachers and for students
the depth of the table that currently is
drawn on the floor
is 500 so it's up to there i've been
here for a while
and i noticed how hard it is to work in
groups i like to have a new design that
allows us to see other group members
screens so we can work together more
effectively
what are you guys doing at the moment we
are attempting to make an article about
the library
okay so i'm currently looking at what
project management
is involved in the redesign of the
library and
specifically i'm looking at funding
management and ergonomics
so funding management like how the money
is going to be distributed and also
ergonomics how it all fits together in
the library
okay so our group decided to make a
comic
yeah okay that is